un jour au détour d'une conversation ta
maman m'a dit que même aujourd'hui en
tant que champion du monde tu fais
encore la vaisselle ça paraît tout bête
non maintenant je la fais plus
maintenant je la fais plus mais c'est
vrai que pendant longtemps ma mère
voulait que je le fasse pour euh pour
que j'ai le la valeur des choses euh que
je puisse faire les choses par moi-même
et que je sois pas assisté et et que je
je je prenne conscience de la valeur des
choses que chaque chose a une raison et
que chaque chose se mérite et mais elle
me fait d'autres rappels qui sont
parfois encore mais c'est une maman on a
tous une maman et on sait tous que ça
fonctionne comme ça